tension à la frontière entre la pologne
et la biélorussie face à un nouvel
afflux de migrants l'armée polonaise a
été déployée varsovie accuse minsk sous
le coup de menaces de sanctions
d'utiliser ces migrants pour faire
pression sur l'union européenne
oui à la situation s'est tendue d'heure
en heure hier on va le voir sur ces
images filmées acoustique à la frontière
biélorusse elle des centaines de
migrants ont tenté d'abattre les
barbelés pour passer du côté polonais
face à eux derrière la clôture les
militaires polonais déployés en nombre
elles des images qui ont provoqué de
nombreuses réactions à l'international
et pour faire le point on va retrouver
notre correspondant en toi de clairoix
[Musique]
antoine claireaux bonjour alors vous
êtes en biélorussie quelle est la
situation est exactement sur place là où
vous trouvez
vous les biens y fier le camp de fortune
que vous pouvez apercevoir derrière moi
est en train doucement de se réveiller
les hommes pour chercher du bois dans la
forêt afin de nourrir les dizaines des
centaines de feux de camp qui sont qui
crépite ici sachant que les temples se
trouve littéralement à quelques mètres
seulement de cette clôture de fils de
fer barbelés qui symbolise cette
frontière alors ici il ya 24 ans il n'y
avait personne encore tout le monde est
arrivé hier vous l'avez rappelé des
centaines de migrants qui ont tenté de
forcer ce passage vers la pologne vers
l'union européenne ayant été refoulés
ils ont décidé de rester sur place et de
retenter leur chance un peu plus tard
mais les conditions ici sont très
précaires détente simplement plusieurs
des femmes des enfants donc des hommes
également bien sûr qu'ils dorment
parfois à même le sol sachant que les
températures ont été négatives cette
nuit - 2 - 3 degrés sachant qu'il ya ici
alors nous a dit nous a donné ce chiffre
d'à peu près de 1500 migrants en sachant
qu'il y ait encore d'autres des
centaines d'autres migrants qui se
trouvent dans les forêts un petit peu
plus loin dans cette direction je
propose maintenant de revenir sur les
événements d'hier avec une réaction des
autorités biélorusses
les représentants des forces de l'ordre
polonaise on déploie des avions et des
équipements pour exercer une pression
psychologique
en outre du gaz lacrymogène a été
dispersée en réponse au recours excessif
aux moyens spéciaux certains des
réfugiés sont passés à l'action de façon
résolue et ont commencé à démolir les
barrières polonaise casaque rouge des
comptes
sachant que là le du côté polonais on a
également réagi dénonçant accusant le
gouvernement d' ou le qashqaï les
autorités biélorusses d'instrumentaliser
cette crise migratoire écoutez
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à la
situation la plus difficile depuis le
début de la crise à la frontière entre
la pologne et la biélorussie
nous avons affaire à un autre élément de
sédières hybride
les etats unis ont également réagi tout
comme l'otan qui sont bien sûr qu'ils
sont allés dans le même sens que les
autorités polonaises en attendant ici se
trouvent plusieurs centaines plusieurs
milliers de migrants qui sont bien
décidés à passer de l'autre côté de
cette frontière alors qu'on entend en
boucle inlassablement de jour comme de
nuit le message des autorités polonaises
transmis dans les haut parleurs
quand quoi seul le passage le passage
vers la pologne est autorisée uniquement
via les points de passage officiel merci
beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine gayraud à la
frontière entre la biélorussie et la
pologne ce matin merci